it's a mixed bag this week as
multinationals migration and state
visits dominate welcome to the agenda
can you imagine paying thousands in tax
when in fact you earn millions and even
billions while naming and shaming the
big uns is part in the past of the war
against multinationals and their tax
avoidance schemes Facebook is the latest
big bucks company to agree to pay the
British government millions in tax
after years of criticism but back in
Brussels the European Parliament
spearheaded a europe-wide movement for a
common consolidated corporate tax base
the EU executive are followed through
with a new proposal while those rules
are finalized at the Parliament on
Monday MEP s will talk with tax
representatives and on Tuesday there'll
be talks with representatives from Ikea
McDonald's Apple and Google at the Tax
Committee a deal of turkey was heralded
by German Chancellor Angela Merkel as a
potential breakthrough in the migrant
crisis but here in Strasbourg MEP say
that politicians are playing with
people's lives
Macedonia Slovenia and Austria have all
put up temporary borders to stop
refugees spilling on mass from Greece as
a result Greece has been forced to stop
refuse coming to the mainland from
islands with a situation at a precipice
was a deal with Turkey the right to me
or can a long advocated holistic
approach should be the rub on Wednesday
the civil liberties committee will vote
on the drunk report and now with the
news in brief we agreed to work on the
basis of the following first evil it is
our just inked a deal with Turkey on the
refugee crisis and made concessions for
its potential membership of the EU on
Tuesday MEP will vote on a turkey
progress report linked to that very
agreement also look out for another EU
summit on Thursday and Friday next week
attended by President Martin Schultz
poor health old age and lack of care on
Monday the Legal Affairs Committee held
a hearing looking to push for new rules
to better protect the most vulnerable
does the law across the EU protect the
rights of minors accused or suspected of
a crime a vote to ensure that - of
access illegal justice takes place on
Monday a vote to bank an institutional
deal on the technical pillar of the
Fourth Way web package takes place on
Tuesday and finally Tuesday will see a
state visit from a near neighbor from
which country Moldova and later on in
the week thinking in Jordan that will
also pop into the parliament and that's
all we have this agenda take care and
enjoy the week
you